[Musique]
avant même qu'il atterrit sa Moscou la
télévision chinoise diffusait fièrement
ses images d'une capitale russe prête à
recevoir son président en grande pompe
ce sont les médias de la Russie qui ont
pris la relève
[Musique]
et même prendre une visite officielle de
trois jours à Moscou la toute première
du président chinois depuis que son ami
Vladimir Poutine a envahi l'Ukraine
un voyage des plus stratégiques que
Pékin décrit de son côté comme une
mission de paix d'abord et avant tout
mais dès les toutes premières minutes de
leur tête à tête les allégeances étaient
claires
vous serez toujours un ami précieux à
déclarer et c'est Jinping Poutine a beau
être accusé de crimes de guerre par le
Tribunal pénal international il n'est
pas si seul et isolé qu'on le crois
c'est une confirmation de l'amitié de la
pluie ensuite de la chaîne envers la
Russie puis c'est pour aider la Russie à
trouver une porte de sortie en fait
c'est dans l'intérêt de la Chine que la
Russie ne perde pas cette garde selon
l'ex ambassadeur du Canada en Chine il
faut bien se méfier des intentions de
Pékin qui essaient de jouer les
médiateurs avec un plan de paix en 12
points qui propose entre autres un
Cécile feu en Ukraine sans condition
claire un plan de paix déjà rejeté par
l'Ukraine
avec son homologue chinois cette semaine
une visite que Washington surveille de
loin avec méfiance
bien que nous accueillons toute
initiative qui met de l'avant une paix
durable à des secrétaire d'État
américain
la visite surprise de Vladimir Poutine
hier à Mario Paul on dit long d'ailleurs
à ce chapitre des images diffusées par
les médias russe le montre faire la
tournée de la ville que son armée occupe
depuis déjà un an mais qu'il considère
désormais partie intégrale de la Russie
on
occupe le territoire c'est à nous autres
qui sur le plein déologique il faut pas
oublier que ces deux pays qui sont
complètement alignés des pays
autoritaires qui disent que les
États-Unis sont la principale menace
mais jusqu'où ira la Chine pour garantir
une victoire de la Russie demeure la
question principale de ce grand voyage
il serait pas surpris c'est que la
chaîne utilise des intermédiaires comme
l'Iran la Corée du Nord ou la
Biélorussie pour envoyer des armes et
aider l'ami Poutine est à Moscou jusqu'à
mercredi si Tamara Alteresco
Radio-Canada Montréal